if you find yourself nose-to-nose with a
great white man-eating shark the thing
to do is to leave the water quietly just
as if your only thought was to rub in
more suntan lotion if I was a great
white shark I would bite you if I was a
great white I wouldn't bite you but I
swim right next to you if I was a great
white
I wouldn't bite you but it's when right
next to you and ask you how you do then
you look at
and pull out a harpoon and try to shoot
me then I realize how kind of really
hungry I am right now sorry about your
leg I'll be back in a while pull the
rest don't stress
my sister will be back to clean up this
mess relax kick back it's only a great
white shark attack ruff
if I was a great white oh and bite you
but a swim right next to you if I was a
great white I wouldn't bite you let it
swim right next to you cos sharks like
surfing to you paddle out chasing the
fat sets and pushing the sunset then I
realized I've never seen a seal so fat
and low sorry about your arm
I just didn't know think fast swim back
you you still look like the seal your
wetsuit so black and red
great white sharks died 4,000 feet swim
across the world
damn isn't that deep forty million years
and they haven't changed apex predator
survivals the game
ambush now is how they hunt seven rows
of teeth Lorenzini in the front oh I
love the great white shark their bellies
are white and the rest is dark and if I
might just happen to be a great white
shark named ABC
oh you know I wouldn't fight you know if
I was a great white I wouldn't bite you
but I swim right next to you if I was a
great white I wouldn't bite you but I
swim right next to you cuz it's my ocean
too so please keep it clean as I can be
wicked me and I got sharp teeth and if I
realize that you don't care about the
sea well that means you don't care about
me oh well that's fine I'll just rip you
and bloody half this time you if I was a
great white
if I was a great white shirt rock